[Music]
just a few days ago the pentagon
confirmed that a 2019
video of a ufo sighting is actually real
it was a ufo
the video shows a pyramid-shaped object
flying over u.s navy destroyer
this is the very first time the public
has seen video from this incident
the ufo footage was leaked to a
filmmaker called jeremy
corbell who joins us tonight to explain
all of this
jeremy thanks so much for coming on tell
us
where this was shot what are we looking
at here
yeah so i obtained and released uh
videos and photographic
evidence of ufos swarming our warships
so the green video is night vision
that's from the uss russell it wasn't
just one
pyramid shaped craft it was multiple
these were swarms
i also released with my mentor in
journalism george knapp
also released from the uss omaha which
looks like thermal imagery
he released three photos the day prior
to mine so we're trying to get this out
to continue uh elevating the
conversation because it's very important
we have it right now
yeah you think i mean those are not
weather balloons
those are clearly autonomous aircraft of
some kind that are as you put it
swarming us military craft
so these are there are two options
control
these nicely put their intelligence
control and they're flying with impunity
tucker within our airspace and they can
outmaneuver
outperform anything that we seem to have
their
mode of transportation is uh seems
magical to us
it's unbelievable and now finally we're
having a rational sober
discussion about this because we don't
know what these are
we don't know the nature of the
technology we need to find out who's
operating them
and also what the intent is so it's a
really exciting time
to be learning about ufos because now
we're having a complete
tipping point with the transparency and
hopefully we'll be getting more answers
soon
this must have scared the crap out of
the u.s military i mean their job is to
defend the country and themselves and
hear these aircraft violate their
airspace
quickly do you believe that they
sincerely don't know
what these things are they don't we have
the best
we have the best military on planet
earth the greatest intelligence agencies
these are true unknowns and they were
swarming
our you know military arsenals this
they're seen over nuclear facilities
this is documented
we need to find out who is operating
these vehicles
yeah nicely put jeremy corbell i
appreciate you coming on time i hope we
see you again thank you
no problem thank you